shift gears for a minute put your 5g hat
on
we're starting to see some of our allies
push back against huawei push back
against their systems effectively being
infiltrated
do you think that we can turn this
around to where
chinese don't literally have the keys to
the kingdom and the ability to spy on
everybody so
it goes right to the same problem of
wall street and its industry
industry has a stranglehold on on so and
theoretically the city of london because
if you think about it
what what the united states started with
this um
auctioning of spectrum and the rise of
the of the telecommunications networks
those have essentially become toll roads
toll roads that
the telecom operators maintain
and they were in the beginning it kind
of made sense because
the technology kind of required that you
built
networks this way but as technology
you know evolved we found our stuff and
we find ourselves today stuck on toll
roads
when in reality we could open up this
vast swath
uh you know it's like it's like that
that that scene from the movie
independence day where he's driving
all the rvs across the desert and you've
got this salt lake
you know bed that you're driving on you
have all of this space
that's what that's what we have in
spectrum
that's what technology can actually give
us access today
but the telecom industry says no i want
to keep you on my toll road
and so that's why and the real estate
developers say get rid of the toll roads
that's great property we can develop it
but here's the deal
here's the brilliance of that whole idea
it actually plays into huawei because
because they're stuck
on these toll roads and they're in the
rickety
and they they they don't have the latest
equipment
but what incentive do they have to build
on it because they haven't made their
investment back from 4g
right so along comes huawei and says hey
i'll sell that to you
hey i'll give it to you why why
why would they give you the
the infrastructure why would they build
it for you
because what silicon valley found out is
it's not
the toll road it's the data that rides
on the toll road
that's where the doubt the value is
right yeah i mean
that's what they want they want the data
greg greg
ipp had a great story in in the wall
street journal a few weeks ago
and he basically plotted out on a graph
and showed that that huawei's got almost
a third
of global telecommunications equipment
in its possession
almost a third if it gets to 50 it will
effectively be globally dominant
and this is this is the data gathering
equipment that we're talking about here
so so you know the you know the um stock
multiple on att
verizon t-mobile you also know the stock
mo
multiple on facebook amazon and google
right they're not
they're not in the same class okay same
zip code so so one is
one has got toll roads and the other
one's got data right
okay so the chinese look at this and
they say hmm
americans dominated 4g the guys that
the guys that built the toll roads
didn't make any money but the guys that
took the data and built the app services
and business models on top of those toll
roads
they're the ones that cleaned up
we cannot break into that why because
the two companies that control the
platform for that are apple and google
android and ios now like
even huawei as hard as huawei tried
they could not break into that because
they have they they have the dominant
position
well they are they're called monopolies
for a reason exactly
so so what did they say they said well
we're not even going to go there
we're just going to go to the next thing
and the next thing is not a smartphone
world
so android and ios don't get to play
right it's about
cameras and machines and everything's
connected so they're just basically
going and they're
they're basically going doing an end
around and their
their business model is this huawei you
go build the roads
baidu alibaba and 10 cent they'll be the
monetization arm
right they'll take the data they'll
monetize it but it's not just for
economic growth it's also for social and
political control because that's the way
their system is
right and then huawei
we'll just force baidu alibaba and 10
cent to
fund your effort right so make sense
if you were if you were going to do the
same thing in um
here in the united states what you do is
you tax the tech companies
to pay for a new nationwide
you know really great 5g can we do that
well
we could if we wanted to but we don't
we don't want to we want to allow why
can't we
want to i mean why can't we make it a
matter of national security to want to
well i mean we are so you know i get to
i get to the white house and um
my colleagues at the national economic
council when i say hey we need to do
some
industrial policy says um no
america doesn't do industrial policy i
said well you know there's other nations
that do
and we're getting our ass handed to us
yeah because we're not
and so so the recent congressional
report even that came out from
um the republicans that did a report on
the china study
if you look in the report and you look
at what they did for 5g
there's nothing in there why because the
telecom industry does not want the
federal government
to tell them how to build the next
network oh by the way
they're not actually building the next
network because they're stuck
in 4g they're stuck on the smartphone
and what china did is said okay china
unicom china mobile
i you know in the past we've let you
build your own networks
you guys are going to build one network
and you're going to share it remember
what i said
because the technology now allows you to
open up
vast swaths of spectrum and if you build
you know more than one physical network
in your country
so think about this you have two
companies
this one has to spend a billion dollars
and this is a notional small country so
he spends a billion dollars
building a telecom network this one
spends a billion dollars
on a telecom network and then they're
fighting for customers
meanwhile the customers get half the
speed
and what else they pay twice the price
so half the speed at twice the price
because the throughput when you break
them up like that in separate
physical networks it doesn't it doesn't
make economic sense so your cap
so for us in the united states our capex
is four times our opex is four times
and our speed that the customer sees is
one fourth
this is so this is the the the
the technology this is what the
technology has given us but our industry
models
today are based on old technology the
chinese
uh you know i'm pretty sure they read my
report and said okay china you come
china mobile you're going to build one
network you're going to share it
yep and be efficient about it yeah i
mean we don't i mean
in our family we've got one person has
at t and the other person has verizon
for when we travel
so when one person loses loses coverage
the other person has it
and that's that that's kind of a very
real world example of
of what's taking place